first chop onions ginger then fry them
in hot olive oil add cinnamon and to
give the mix a subtle sweet note a pinch
of sugar then seasoned chopped cooked
chicken thighs and add to the mix pour
in chicken stock and then simmer
stirring whole lightly beaten eggs which
thicken the sauce and cook and in sliced
almonds then set aside to cool now build
your pasta phyllo is another pastry as
tricky to make it home but you can buy
fantastic phyllo Xochitl brush each
sheet with melted butter and lay four
sheets into a greased baking tin
spoon in half of the fantastic aromatic
chicken filling add four more buttered
sheets of phyllo pastry
and simply piling the rest of the
delicious chicken finally cover with a
couple of sheets of filo and fold over
all the drape sides brush with more
butter then bake in the hot oven for 10
to 15 minutes until the top is crispy
and golden brown you want all the feeler
paste wonderfully crunchy and golden so
turn over and return for another 10
minutes
when done remove and for a different but
delicious sweet finishing touch dust
lightly with icing sugar and cinnamon
intently aromatic sweet and savory
crispy and succulent an extraordinary
pie that has to be tasted to be believed
cut into disks spoon the mixture into
one half of the disk leaving roughly a
centimeter border around the edge brush
the edge of one half of the disk with
egg traditionally we always put jam in
there but chocolate and doughnuts
Wow to die for add the cream